ce soir il ya une personne que vous
n'avez pas vu depuis longtemps depuis
très longtemps valérie ce et qui tenait
absolument à vous revoir
regarde moi quand il regarde pas ce que
je veux savoir ce que comme on a de gros
moyens on a décidé de re faire exprès
pour voir l'émission on à gros moyens
auxquels sa meilleure vente de l'année
on a décidé de refaire il serait pour
vous l'émission y'a que la vérité qui
compte
naga derrière ce rideau ce rideau se
cache une personne venue spécialement
pour ce et vous choisirez si oui ou non
vous voulez ouvrir ce rideau valérie
bene et pourquoi je me suis embrouillé
avec la personne vous allez voir c'est
un exédent est à découvrir qui se cache
derrière le rideau
nous avons une première vidéo pour vous
avec un indice regardez on dit que la
véritable amitié c'est comme un roseau
elle peut se plier ce temps mais ne se
brise jamais c'est vrai donc c'est à
dire que ça quelqu'un avec qui j'étais
très très très amis et mes amis qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis longtemps avec qui
vous étiez très très amis une amie
quelqu'un qui pourrait avoir quelque
chose à vous annoncer volée ouais ça se
passe bien avec nos collaborateurs en
général ouais mais c'est travailler il
ya longtemps
oui et j'ai travaillé longtemps avec ses
pairs ce oui je vais demander à la
personne d'ailleurs le rideau de dire
bonjour à valérie bénaïm vous allez me
aulas c'est moi j'ai tout de suite
reconnu la voix citoyenne
bah oui c'est le droit d'être appliquée
ouais ça y est je crois savoir alors d'y
arriver là et vous savez vous mettre
devant le rideau venez avec moi
valérie mais là il est ce que vous avez
une idée de qui il s'agit alors
quelqu'un avec qui j'ai travaillé
longtemps que je ne vois plus beaucoup
mais qui a été très très proche de moi
j'ai une petite idée
si c'est un homme en tout cas j'ai une
petite idée oui mettez-vous la valérie
et vous allez faire non nous inquiète
pas venir que du mois est ce que vous
voulez voir cette personne ou pas ah ben
oui je suis très très curieuse mais
normalement voir celui de l'argent il
est mauvais est ce qu'on peut avoir
est ce qu'on peut avoir un petit mot de
la personne atteinte en deux secondes
juste une question attendait d'eux lâche
moi pourquoi tu veux me tenir la main il
ya un truc à rincon écouter écouter la
personne
ça doit s'attendre avec n'ai pas vécu
très longtemps ce que tu veux savoir qui
c'est ok je pense à laurent fontaine
laurent fontaine qui travaille avec toi
qui étais donc producteurs producteurs
amis il était témoin de mariage de mon
ex mari sont plus raconté que j'aime
énormément plu s'est impliqué samedi moi
ça serait plus sûr de jouer à wii ça me
ferait très plaisir si c'est lui est ce
que tu veux bien ou alors il nous attend
parce que si c'est lui c'est pas dur une
fontaine qui me kim qui tu savais que c
est ce que parce qu'on peut réécouter la
voix c'est leur côté trop doit-on doigt
sur le négoce ah ah ah c'est pas leur en
direct ou pas il ya une marque au sol
mais t'es bête c'est pour les salles se
calme enfin l'émission de 13 km pour les
axes comme heureusement voilà est-ce que
tu mourir le rideau des dates ont tourné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez laurent vous pensez qu'à laurent
fontaine est ce que laurent fontaine
maintenant aller j'étais dans l'oeuf ça
c'est bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
montanes et là tu vois alors qu'il était
fin d'année ou pas ça fait plaisir de
revoir valérie et laurent est un amour
devenu une voix je sais tout sur scène
je dis juste cette vanne donc voilà on
va dire merci à leur domaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]